[Musique]
à
e
artem jilenkov bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle singer view vous
voudrais avoir votre point de vue sur la
géopolitique mondiale sur l'actualité
comment ça va comment allez vous qu'est
ce qui se passe en russie qu'est ce qui
se passe un peu partout dans le monde
bonjour et comme d'habitude je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité et un à
personne
l'ambassadeur aussi si vous voulez à
paris vous êtes le numéro deux de
l'ambassade de russie tout à fait c'est
comme ça c'est mon troisième poste en
france et
depuis octobre 2015 j'assume la
responsabilité du ps conseiller chef de
mission adjoint de l'ambassade de aussi
en france donc écouter
comment comment ça va vous avez vous
avez dit d'agglo bonnement évidemment
comme tout le monde répond ça va bien
mais si on prend l'aspect international
s'il ne prend les situations dans le
monde donc ça va pas très bien à notre
avis parce que le monde
devient de plus en plus instable les
conflits se multiplient
la situation
devient de plus de plus en plus
compliqué dans plusieurs pays du monde
mais tout d'abord évidemment dans cette
région qui était toujours assez
compliqué mais aujourd'hui il est devenu
vraiment
notre problème numéro un pour tout le
monde c'est le proche et moyen-orient
cette région depuis plusieurs années
déjà et déstabilisé et si autrefois à
l'époque on pouvait parler de cette
crise arabo israélien ou palestino
israélien il y avait cette guerre entre
irak iran mais à part ça la région
étaient plus ou moins
stable même si nous prenons l'organiste
ans à l'époque de 7
c'est un trait des forces soviétiques en
afghanistan
même à l'époque la la situation en
afghanistan était beaucoup plus stable
qu'aujourd'hui
donc nous constatons une crise énorme
autour de la série crise qui implique
plusieurs pays de la région
nous constatons la guerre sans fin au
yémen la guerre oubliée par tout le
monde tandis que la lettre pertes
l'humanitaire les pertes de la
population civile se calcule déjà par
par des milliers et des milliers
et tout ça
tous ces victimes tous ses pertes
c'est le résultat de cette opération
menée par
l'arabie saoudite
tout le monde est conscient et même
temps tout le monde ne parle pas de ces
bombardements aveugles qui se produisent
tout le temps dans cette région de
peyrens hull
rabique
nous avons là la situation
très urgente et
très aiguë en libye
on a constaté la défragmentation de ce
pays après
après l'entrée dans le jeu des pays
occidentaux surtout de la france et le
grand bétail qui ont contribué au chute
du régime de kadhafi mais qu'ils n'ont
pas et poulet les nouvelles autorités du
puits dans la reconstruction de libye
donc en résultat nous avons
en chaos
évidemment aujourd'hui la société
internationale a fait beaucoup pour
essayer de prendre les choses en main et
pour aider le gouvernement provisoire à
de prendre sous leur contrôle la
situation en pays mais vous savez très
bien qu'il y à un facteur des ducatistes
en tant nationaux il ya le facteur de
cépages de 2,7 défragmentation du pays
ce conflit larvé entre le groupe et
tripoli donc la situation est très très
compliqué dans cette région et en même
temps cette déstabilisation de la libye
a renforcé les forces radicales des
forces extrémistes
dans cette région de l'afrique
équatoriale je parle
je parle de lui comme je parle de
nigeria du cameroun du tchad avec cette
organisation
qui est rattachée à al qaïda boko haram
justement donc vous voyez
cette instabilité
dans la région du proche et moyen orient
a déjà des conséquences pour les régions
beaucoup plus éloigné je n'ai pas évoqué
mais il faut le faire
les tensions entre l'arabie saoudite et
l'iran
en réalité c'est presque la guerre en
procuration ce que nous voyons au yémen
dans proxy partant par proxy justement
c'est un pays où se heurte les intérêts
de la raba de l'arabie saoudite sunnite
est de l'iran chiite faut pas oublier le
liban qui est toujours où la situation
reste très fragile à cause de cette
crise politique interne sans fin
l'absence du président
nous nous ne nous devons évidemment
évoqué l'afghanistan où les forces de
talibans ont pris sur leurs contrôles
koundouz et maintenant l'armée se bat
pour reprendre cette ville très
importante en afghanistan mais toute
cette situation nous démontre combien la
situation est compliquée en afghanistan
la france avec les autres partenaires de
la coalition se prépare à épauler les
forces irakien à reprendre mossoul la
plus grande une des plus grands pays de
l'irak prix pas pris prise par parra
l'état islamique par par le doj donc
voilà nous pouvons continuer à parler de
tout ce compte de tous ces problèmes et
nommera de la région qui déstabilisent
non seulement la région mais qui crée
des tensions
à l'échelle mondiale je voudrais qu'on
aborde l'aspect de déstabilisation par
des facteurs extérieurs par proxy on
entend dire qu'il y à 89 nationalité de
jihadistes en syrie quel est votre point
de vue quelles sont leurs modes de
financement et qui tire les ficelles
là
nous connaissons ce problème
selon notre propre expérience parce que
on a déjà rencontré ce phénomène des
jihadistes étrangers entier génie
surtout lors de la deuxième opération
antiterroriste a du génie ce que là on a
rencontré pas mal à des gens de ce type
là est
certains parmi eux ont occupé une place
importante dans le système et à rachiq
du commandement des rebelles des
terroristes
anthony donc pour nous c'est pas c'est
pas notre première expérience
mais effectivement ce phénomène
a
en série a connu vraiment
un grand essor en grand succès c'est un
peu le dire parce que
selon notre estimation
une grande partie des gens armés qui
lutte aujourd'hui contre le gouvernement
de damas
je peux pas vous donner le pourcentage
mais en tout cas il s'agit de dizaines
de pourcent ce sont des étrangers venus
de différents coins du monde pour
combattre pour cette cause du dess de
l'état islamique pour la création de
calais fat
mondiale parce que initialement vous
savez que je te paierai cette
organisation s'appelait
état islamique de les ventes et de
l'iban
et
deux séries de lire et de l'évent c'est
à dire le vent le vent c'est à dire
se proposait de créer en qu'elles
effacent le territoire assez limité donc
ma après ils ont changé d'avis l'ont
rebaptisé leur mouvement en le nommant
tout simplement l'état islamique
tout en comprenant que
la région limité c'est pas suffisante
c'est pas suffisant il faut tout
simplement créer ou khalifa on état
islamique à l'échelle mondiale et
c'était la raison de notre décision
assez
difficile à prendre
devenir un force en syrie pour soutenir
le gouvernement légitime de ce pays pour
éviter l'effondrement total de l'état
sait rien et pour ne pas créer
la base pour l'élargissement d'une zone
de contrôle de l'état islamique sur
toute la région parce que nous sommes
profondément persuadé que la position en
soi disant modérés ainsi rien qui
d'ailleurs existe
je pense que c'est une réalité mais nous
sommes profondément persuadé que
les capacités de cette opposition
modérée est donc comparable avec les
capacités de l'état islamique et au cas
de l'effondrement de l'état syrien
cette opposition modérée seraient rasées
de la carte politique de syrie par le
mouvement de l'état islamique par le
moment du doj et après celui liban après
c'est l'arabie saoudite a pressé
l'egypte où la situation aussi reste
très fragile donc c'était la raison de
notre
implication dans le conflit c'est rien
aux côtés de l'armée de bachar al assad
justement parce que
nous savons très bien que
l'opposition armée radical et
non pas radicale et ceux tenus par les
sponsors étrangers qu'elles sont morts
écoutez
nous avons plusieurs
plusieurs informations qui émanent de
différentes sources que le soutien
provient de certains pays du golfe
lequel a écouté j'aimerais bien de ne
pas citer ces pays
parce que vous comprenez très bien qu'il
faut donner des preuves concrètes
je pense que
les services les autorités compétentes
en france
aux états unis en russie possèdent de
telles informations et là je ne veux pas
citer les pays où les connaissez très
bien de ces pays et les internautes
qui surfent
sur internet ont lu pas mal
d'informations le pas mal de de
pas mal de rumeurs pas mal
d'informations plus ou moins
convaincantes
concernant ce sujet mais nous comprenons
très bien que toutes ces armes tout ce
financement tous ces munitions ne
peuvent pas parvenir du ciel
évidemment il ya des trophées de guerre
mais il ya en soutien logistique
qui
arrive qui arrivait dès le début de
cette guerre civile en syrie pour nous
c'est un des facteurs qui nous a fait
prendre cette décision comme je vous dis
difficile à prendre parce que après
notre expérience en afghanistan envoyer
de troupes envoyées nos pilotes à
centaine km à centaines
milliers kilomètres de la russie en
syrie c'est un risque mais c'est une
risque pour nous raisonnable parce que à
ne faut pas oublier que ce qui se passe
en syrie se trouve ou plutôt la syrie se
trouve à 800 km de la frontière russe
est pour nous la lutte contre l' état
islamique en série signifie la lutte
contre les futurs djihadistes qui
pourrait un jour venir lire audience
venir déstabiliser les pays limitrophes
de la russie c'est à dire les pays de
l'asie centrale aussi bien que la russie
comme tel on a vu qu'on a vu récemment
la crise se pose ou polarisée avec
vraiment une augmentation des tensions
avec la syrie entre les etats-unis la
russie et la question je vais vous poser
qui est très direct est ce que vous êtes
en train de vous préparer un conflit
ouvert nucléaire avec les états unis
bien sûr que non
moi je disais que je me souviens plus si
j'ai évoqué ce sujet lors de ma
précédente
visite chez vous mais moi je pense que
c'est une c'est un sujet tabou nous tous
nous devons
bien comprendre que cette option est
absolument impossible est-ce qu'il est
envisagé faux pas même envisager cette
option sinon il faut pas le faire parce
que là nous n'avons aucune raison de
parler de cette option horrible je
refuse en tout cas de devaux quai et 2
d'analyser les l'éventualité de cette
tournure de choses mais mais
effectivement
les tensions ont beaucoup monté depuis
quelques quelques temps entre la russie
et les etats unis
après
après la fin de ce fait le feu
qui était le résultat des langues
adaptation de longues négociations entre
les chefs de la diplomatie russe et
américaine chez nous avons annoncé votre
venue sur internet depuis mercredi
d'ailleurs merci d'avoir répondu aussi
vite à notre sollicitation les
internautes nous ont fait remonter
énormément de coupures de presse russes
en russe qu'anglaise américaine j'ai pu
voir passer devant mes yeux des
exercices militaires en russie qui
engagerait 40 millions de civils 200 ou
300 milles personnel militaire
46000 40 millions de civils oui dans
quelle forme
participation d' exercice de frappes sur
votre territoire puis j'ai vu
passer des papiers d'ailleurs couchettes
ou des as posté il n'ya pas loin d'une
demi heure que les déclarations de
généraux américains qui expliquait si
vous voulez que je vous donne exactement
le titre qui expliquait que la l'un des
généraux américains 2.1 conflit
extrêmement meurtriers avec la russie
est quasiment certain
écoutez là je ne peux pas commenter les
paroles des généraux américains les
généraux russes ne parle pas de cette
éventualité les généraux russes prévient
que nous avons suffisamment de moyens en
syrie pour a riposté au cas où
mais nous avons ses moyens depuis le
début de notre opération en syrie le
conflit ou plutôt
les
les incidents sont toujours possibles et
voilà pourquoi même après l'arrêt des
des négociations entre la russie et les
etats unis sur le plus tôt de la commet
sur le plutonium non non non la n avait
pas des négociations regretté m'ont
traitée mais dont je parle de la syrie
l'arrêt des négociations de cet échange
continu entre
les deux ministères affaires étrangères
les deux
ministères de la défense
ne signifie pas l'arrêt à des contacts
entre les médias entre les militaires
pour assurer le des conflits thing pour
la des complications dans le cadre de
désagréments sur le sur la des
complications ça veut dire et les
américains et les russes comprend très
bien que
la situation où l'aviation de deux pays
et présent dans le ciel syrien parce que
les américains mènent leurs propres
opérations antiterroristes et la russie
effectué sa propre opération
antiterroriste à côté du gouvernement
légitime syrien donc la présence de deux
agressions dans le ciel de la syrie des
mondes en compta permanents entre
militaires entre les militaires pour
éviter les incidents les conflits pour
assurer cette des complications et je
voudrais bien mettre l'accent sur ce
fait donc d'abord on continue à parler
avec les américains en principe sur la
série et nos deux ministres va faire des
affaires étrangères ont déjà se sentait
déjà échangé des coups de fil après
l'annonce par les autorités américains
de l'arrêt de ses contacts sur à sur le
sait le feu
donc ils continuent nous continuons à en
parler avec les américains et les
militaires continuent à se contacter
pour éviter justement les accrochages
par erreur à des bavures et c'est une
erreur que votre ambassade en syrie
était été bombardés donc c'est long une
autre selon notre avis c'était une
action
préparée effectué par hadja pratham nous
sera qui a changé un petit peu son nom
son étiquette mais pas
le fait que les états unis bloquent la
condamnation par l'onu qu'est ce que ça
vous a fait
à écouter pour nous cela reflète la
politique ambiguë des états unis la
politique de double standard
les avis ont démontré une nouvelle fois
que ils ont des relations très
violent très ambivalente à l'égard de
l'opposition radicale
syrienne puis c'est dommage c'est
dommage mais c'est pas pour la première
fois et
on espérait de convaincre les américains
de soutenir cette résolution bout de
cette déclaration qui
juste met l'accent sur la nécessité de
respecter la convention de vienne et qui
souligne
le statut spécifique des ambassades dans
tout le monde y compris en syrie et non
pas ceux tenus lors notre projet ou
plutôt ils ont voulu d'introduire
certains disposition qui n'étaient pas
acceptables pour la partie russe est où
là pour toi
sur l'art soit sur la responsabilité de
la russie
pour cette rigueur détention en syrie
voilà pour pour dire si vous voulez pour
dire s'ils voulaient que c'est notre
tort que c'est notre responsabilité
le fait que la bassa de russie a été
bombardé c'est le résultat des démarches
des activités russes en syrie voilà
c'était les des américains tandis que
pour nous ce n'est pas acceptable on
voulait juste accuser la tacc contre la
représentation diplomatique parce qu'on
sait jamais dans n'importe quel pays du
monde n'importe quelle représentation
diplomatique pour être attaqué et si
nous
si nous ne réagissons pas à ce type
d'action
cela peut amener à des à des choses
inacceptables
quand votre commandement en syrie a
annoncé qu'il abattrait tout avion et
tout missile en direction de bachar
el-assad de son armée
comment les américains ont perçu ça
maintenant que vous avez mis des s-300
et s-400 je crois bien maintenant sont
arrivés voilà justement je voulais ce
que j'ai dit déjà s 400 étaient présents
sur le sol syrien dès le début de
l'opération ou en tout cas très très
rapide très rapidement après le début de
l'opération et s 300 étaient arrivés
avec la version russe pour assurer la
protection de la production de notre
base voilà écoutez oui on a prévenu
tous les pays impliqués dans le conflit
dans la situation en syrie dans le
conflit syrien que les frappes contre à
l'armée syrienne contre
le gouvernement légitime série a
aura des conséquences néfastes pour pour
la région et pour la syrie en ce qui
concerne
la pratique j'espère que personne ne va
pas
aller vers l'aggravation de la situation
j'espère que nous allons continuer
ensemble des efforts conjoints pour
essayer de trouver
la solution pour essayer de baisser les
tensions et la russie se prononce pour
pour la continuation à des pourparlers
sur la syrie entre les acteurs clés et
entre les forces syriennes syriennes y
compris le gouvernement et les
différentes branches de l'opposition
sauf évidemment
les groupes reconnus comme terroriste
par
l'organisation des nations unies
la france dans la région quel est votre
regard sur la diplomatie française
vous voyez que
vous avez vu évidemment que
ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur gérard diot a été accueilli à
mouscou par
par messieurs lavrov par notre ministre
des affaires étrangères c'est une visite
éclair et nous avons accepté
immédiatement après à la démente de nos
partenaires français donc vous voyez que
le dialogue très dense
continue
nous est ici à paris nous en tant que
l'ambassade nous sommes en contact
permanent avec nos partenaires et
collègues français
a lui aussi mais on travaille entre les
représentations permanentes
de la russie de la france à new york
partout nous parlons partout nous
échangeons des idées des nos évolutions
des choses mais on constate que la
politique française n'a pas beaucoup
bougé dès le début du conflit
la france mais toujours sur le départ de
bachar al assad sans réfléchir à
l'avenir de la série dans ces situations
là
par contre là l'approchent français a
évolué quelque sorte parce que
initialement la france exigeait le
départ immédiat de bachar al assad
aujourd'hui c'est pas une condition
préalable pour le début des négociations
entre
pour le début de ce dialogue ces
dialogues en terre syrienne
non aujourd'hui la france reconnaît que
bachar al-assad peut rester au pouvoir
en tout cas au début de ses pourparlers
et pendant ces pourparlers
mais
paris exigent toujours le départ
de bachar al assad
le parfum français pour l'heure actuelle
ne peuvent pas imaginer que bachar al
assad pourraient prendre part aux
élections présidentielles organisées
selon conformément à al khor à l'accord
entre toutes les forces syriennes
de ce point de vue paris reste sur le
même
sur la même position mais en même temps
nous partageons avec la france
une idée sur la syrie de futures
sur la série de l'avenir cela syrie
unifier la série qui respecte toutes les
minorités ethniques et toutes les
confessions religieuses
cela à ciry le noble pratiques et laïque
notre analyse ou plutôt nos souhaits
sont les mêmes
nos approches sont différents comment
aboutir à cette série comment aboutir à
la fin des hostilités à la fin de la
guerre civile
là effectivement elle va reconnaître
c'est pas en secret nos approches sont
très différents
la presse occidentale et la
l'intelligentsia française a beaucoup
reproché à la russie
ce qui se passe à alep quelle est votre
vision de ce qui se passe à alep est ce
que c'est un blitzkrieg
est ce que c'est un bombardement totale
et aveugle ou est-ce que vous suspectez
l'injection de
de l'état islamique à travers les fameux
casques blancs syrien quelle est votre
lecture qui qu'est-ce qui se passe
écoutez pour nous ce qui se passe à
l'est aujourd'hui c'est le résultat
des activités des groupes terroristes
infiltrés dans la ville et qui
aujourd'hui en réalité contrôle sept
partis d'alep parce que c'est ce sont
les combattants de josh fattal nous sera
qui tient en main la situation dans
cette ville là et malheureusement le
problème c'est que nos partenaires
américains n'ont pas réussi ce qu'ils
ont promis à faire depuis des mois déjà
séparé les milices de l'opposition
modérée
les troupes les les unités de bouder de
l'opposition modérée
des unités qui appartient des troubles
qui appartient à cette organisation de
jazz brad hand sera ça c'est le problème
primordial le problème crucial nous
avons demandé pendant des mois et des
mois à nos partenaires américains de
respecter leur partie des promesses
puisque nous avons fait tout ce que nous
pouvons faire avec nos partenaires
syrien on a démandé nos partenaires
c'est un appareil arrêter les combats
arrêtés les utilités et la trêve a duré
quelques temps pendant la durée de cette
nouvelle trêve les positions
modérées et radicale qui se sait pts qui
s'est mélangé déjà à alep
à utiliser a profité de cette pause pour
renforcer ses positions tout en
continuant à attaquer
à l'aide de de l'est où se trouve pas
dans à l'aide de l'ouest qui se trouvent
sous contrôle du gouvernement syrien à
l'attaqué dans les positions des troupes
syriens et en bourse renforçant ses
positions partout dans la région dans ce
contexte la cie de l'armée syrienne et
100 la mise en pratique de cette
promesse américaine de séparer les
troupes des radicaux et des modérés
l'armée syrienne a été obligé de rompre
d'arrêter le sait le feu et de riposter
le résultat de cette riposte c'est le
france ihf effectuée aujourd'hui par
l'armée syrienne à alep en ce qui
concerne les versions l'utilisation de
la version
écoutez
je peux parler pour la version russe
toutes nos frappes que nous effectuions
sont bien ciblés ça c'est notre position
de principe nous travaillons autour de
l'aviation russe travaille uniquement
sur les sites sur les cibles qui ont été
reconnus comme
comme cible appartenant comme des
collèges comme des hommes comme des
cibles légitimes
comme des cibles comme des positions des
des forces
de droite hindoue sera comme des points
de commandement est scandé
un stock de munitions etc telle est
notre position si vous identifier un
hôpital où l'armée syrienne identifié un
hôpital comme un centre de commandement
ou une cache terroristes est-ce que vous
rasez l'hôpital
écoutez je suis pas militaire je peux
pas vous et je suis pas sur le terrain
je n'ai pas de toute information dans sa
généralité
mais il faut être réaliste ce sont des
réalistes pendant la guerre je peux
arriver il ya des bavures vous savez
très bien que l'armée américain à
bombarder les troupes syriens q1
soixante deux personnes et en blessant
encore une centaine de personnes c'est
une bavure les bavures sont possibles
sur tout mais quand je parle je parle de
l'aviation russe je souligne chaque
frappe est bien préparé chaque frappe
est effectuée à la base des informations
que nous recevons par tous les moyens
possibles par utilisant tous les moyens
de renseignement donc bien sûr nous
voulons faire tout pour minimiser les
pertes chez les civils je ne peux pas
exclure que ces pertes sont possibles
mais en même temps quand même il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de propagande dans
le contexte actuel à alep
écouter
vraiment
personne ne parle pas de la situation au
yémen où l'aviation de l'arabie saoudite
de ses alliés par apa par cette
coalition indique site bombarde chaque
jour ou presque les différents coins du
yémen en tuant des centaines de
centaines de civils dollars dans des
hôpitaux des
ddt mariage tout ce que vous voulez
personne ne parle pas de cette situation
absolument scandaleuse libye la libye
bon la libye a été bombardée il ya déjà
un bon moment mais
la libye c'est plutôt un exemple de ce
que peut arriver avec un pays si
l'ingérence de l'extérieur n'est pas
accompagnée par
parra le concours politique au
redressement économique et politique de
ce pays comment expliquer que la presse
française et occidentale
ne se polarise que sur la syrie et
oublie le yémen
écoutez je ne peux pas dire que yémen
est oublié de temps en temps
effectivement il ya des articles qui
apparaissent dans tous les grands mass
médias français mais oui ccsl m'écouter
c'est de la politique
c'est la réalité de notre temps oui tout
leur égard sont concentrés sur la série
parce que ces risques un pays plus
importants le peuple est au centre de la
région déjà très
difficile et il m nl et quelque part
ailleurs et les plus c'est que régions
plus éloignées peut-être cela qui peut
expliquer la situation par contre
effectivement je pense que
cette
critique à l'égard de la russie
parfois n'est pas très objectif est très
partiel je voudrais qu'on change de un
petit peu de régions du monde
j'aimerais qu'on aborde les questions
des troupes de l'otan la frontière russe
sur internet on a vu depuis un certain
temps des convois de trains remplis de
char aux couleurs
forêt verte pas aux couleurs du désert
ce dirigeant un peu vers vous
comment vous percevez ça
écoutez oui tout ce qui concerne le
temps là je pense qu'il faut examiner
cette situation
dans toute sa complexité et vous
commencez par les événements du début
des années 90
dans les années 90 quand
la le régime politique en union
soviétique et changer de façon
spectaculaire au plus tôt l'union
soviétique a disparu et
la fédération de russie en quelque sorte
a pris sa place en tout cas l'armée
soviétique qui avait ses bases et qui
était
stationnée dans certains pays de
l'europe de l'est cette arme est celui
qui est devenu l'armée russe et cette
armée a été évacué dans les meilleures
conditions et dans le meilleur délai
peut-être même
alors départ des pays de l'europe de
l'est étaient mal préparés chez nous
parfois les soldats et officiers russes
ont été obligés de passer plusieurs mois
dans les conditions et nos moments
difficiles parce que les bases n'ont pas
été préparés en russie mais on a fait
tout ça
parce que c'était la période c'était
l'époque des illusions l'époque de
romantisme politique l'époque quand on
était
persuadé que le monde change et
que
[Musique]
notre prise de position
nos décisions politiques seront
appréciées à leur juste titre par nos
partenaires occidentaux
il faut dire que l'autre fois à l'époque
au moment de la pérestroïka au moment de
ce rapprochement entre l'occident et
l'union soviétique au moment des
rencontres de gorbatchev avec ses
homologues
occidentaux
on lui a promis de ne pas à l'art jir le
temps après le départ des troupes
soviétiques
par exemple de la république
démocratique allemagne en vue de
réunification avec
la république fédérale allemande
rien n'était signé
rien été promis
dans les lettres ou dans les documents
mais les paroles ont été prononcées et
il ya pas mal de témoins qui confirme
que ces promesses ont été faites c'est
important pour un russe une parole oui
oui tout ça avant je suis d'accord avec
vous mais je pense que comme on dit les
français c'est un homme de parole donc
ça existe un rôle un homme sans parole
est un homme qui ne vaut rien justement
et voilà gorbatchev
a cru parce que je pense que je me
souviens très bien de cette période-là
vraiment c'était le temps de belles
illusions et cet homme c'était un très
bon temps parce que effectivement après
cette longue période de la fermeture on
a enlevé
ce rideau de fer on a fait des
frontières transparente et on attendait
des pas
réciproques du côté de nos partenaires
occidentaux
qu'est-ce que nous avons qu'est ce que
nous avons vu en réponse leurs
agissements de le temps
élargissement qui ne s'arrête pas qui ne
s'arrête pas aujourd'hui
on a vu d'abord les pays de l'europe
de certains de l'europe de de l'est
entrés a le temps l'épi ex républiques
de l'union soviétique qui ont des
frontières communes avec la russie
actuelle on a vu les tentatives de faire
entrer dans le temps certains pays qui
est
qui qui faisait partie même de la
communauté des états indépendants tu
sais oui c'est à dire la géorgie
l'ukraine
on parle de la moldavie aussi
donc tout ça a été très mal perçue par
par la population russe parce que c'est
pas la russie qui s'approche jolivet les
frontières de le temps et c'est le temps
qu'il rapproche qui se rapprochent vers
les frontières de la russie
vous êtes peut-être vous savez quand en
1994 on a signé un accord fondateur en
acte fondateur
entre la russie et le temps qui
prévoyait la création de cet institut
comme conseil russie otan
qui devrait
être un site de dialogue et des échanges
dans tous deux des choses dans toute
situation surtout dans la situation de
crise en a un c'est dingue d'accord avec
le temps que le temps ne déploie pas les
forces considérables
à la frontière ou des exercices de laon
récent la russie donc plusieurs choses
ont été prévus mais avec du temps sous
différents prétextes
sous prétexte de cette fameuse
agressivité russe le temps a pris la
décision de de déployer quatre
bataillons
dans les trois pays baltes lettonie
estonie en lituanie et en pologne
en même temps parallèlement le temps
construit le système antimissile
qui a été pensée comme
comme mon système
saloperie défensive contre les pays
ont des jeunes faire de states
depuis fonderie will pay effondrés ou le
pays irresponsable
on parlait de l'iran ont parlé du corps
et de la corée du nord ont parlé des
terroristes des groupes terroristes et
un groupe hors état mais nos experts
militaires deux experts techniques
ont des soupçons qui sont bien fondés
sur le fait que ce système antimissile
pourrait être dirigé contre les intérêts
stratégiques
de la fédération de russie c'est à dire
contre les forces stratégiques de la
fédération de russie dans la complexité
sûr nous prenons situation d'alors voilà
dans cette complexité dans cette
généralité nous voyons que
[Musique]
les hommes politiques russes et la
population russe a
tout pour être pessimiste
l'infrastructure militaire de l'otan
s'approchent à la frontière russe et les
manoeuvres que vous avez évoquées c'est
juste une partie de
cette tendance qui inquiète beaucoup
parce que le temps quand même c'est pas
une organisation avec des but non
lucratif c'est pas une organisation
humanitaire c'est le bloc militaire le
plus puissante puissant dans l'histoire
de l'humanité c'est un bloc militaire
qui possède tout éventail des armes
modernes des armes nucléaires et quand
on nous dit que l'art jce man 2 le temps
n'est pas dirigé contre la russie
ça nous laisse quand même
perplexe
au début de semaine dernière on a vu
deux bombardiers blackjack s'approchait
des côtes bretonnes puis des côtes
anglaises
des beaux avions d'ailleurs
c'était s'est une petite promenade de
santé c'était pour dire bonjour vous
vous étiez en train de faire une petite
livraison
mais oui je comprends votre question je
comprends votre héros ni écoutés c'est
la pratique courante la pratique
absolument normal
jamais les avions russes ne franchisse
les espaces et les relais les espaces
aériennes des pays étrangers tous les
vols sont effectués dans les couloirs
internationaux tous les vols sont
effectués dans les airs internationaux
sont dans l'espace
internationaux sont transportés je pense
au transpondeur la transe pour écouter
ça c'est une bonne question parce que
nous avons nous à proposer à nos
partenaires de le temps
de d'examiner ensemble toutes les
questions qui concernent les vols dans
la région de la mer baltique pour
commencer parce que là non uniquement
les avions russes mais aussi les avions
de l'otan ce vol sans à transporter nous
avons proposé d'examiner ensemble
comment régler cette affaire est tombé
d'accord sur les vols avec transporteurs
mais pour ça il faut travailler il faut
se réunir il faut évoquer cette
éventualité il faut que les experts et
les cadres techniques les spécialistes
techniques se mettent à la table ronde
et qu'ils se parlent nous sommes ouverts
à
cette des complications dans la mer dans
la région de la mer baltique
et nous avons informé le temps de notre
disponibilité
aujourd'hui on attend la réponse mais je
répète c'était l'initiative russe
continue ses préoccupations d'un
parterre occidentaux et de le temps nous
avons manifesté notre volonté nous avons
dit que nous sommes prêts à discuter ce
sujet
par contre la russie comme tous les
autre pays a le droit d'effectuer les
vols militaires en pleine conformité
avec la droit international les règles
en tant nationaux des vols et je vous
assure que nous respectons
tous ces règles et toutes nos
obligations internationales
par contre oui certains pays
2 le temps s'énerve et s'inquiètent
quand il voit les avions russes qui ne
franchissent pas alors espace est rien
mais qui volent à quelques son fils au
bar cent cinq à trans en quelques
dizaines de kilomètres écoutez ça c'est
le droit des pays de l'otan de l'éveil
leur version et pour accompagner les
avions russes je souligne tout ce que
nous faisons dans les airs est conforme
à la droit international vos deux
bombardiers n'était pas escortés
d'intercepteurs
quand
vous bombardier se sont faits escortés
en dehors
dehors dehors de rien du tout d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils vous n'étiez pas dans le
temps et l'espace aérien français
dans ces cas là est ce que notre
ministre vous appelle ce que votre
ministre nous appelle
écoutez
nous avons des appareils
militaires auprès des ambassades et en
appareil militaire auprès de l'ambassade
de france et en appareil militaire
auprès de l'ambassade de russie
les contacts entre les militaires
existent
techniquement vraiment je sais pas
comment ça fonctionne dans cet état des
choses mais même les pilotes ils sont
munis des radios ils sont toujours en
contact avec
les services techniques sur le sol
voilà c'est ce que je peux vous dire en
tout cas
à ma connaissance
même les autorités militaires françaises
ont reconnu que les avions russes n'ont
pas franchi l'espace aérien français il
était à côté et peut-être les avions
militaires français n'était pas loin
pour observer c'est la pratique normale
entre les militaires de tout le pays est
ce que je peux vous poser une question
indiscrète est-ce que ses avions étaient
chargés je peux pas vous répondre je ne
sais pas je ne pense pas
on va arriver sur la fin notre interview
comme d'habitude on finit par une
question pour les jeunes générations du
mois un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
avant cette question à ce que vous
voulez quelque chose a ajouté est-ce que
vous avez des questions à nous poser
écoutez
j'ai plusieurs questions à vous poser
mais je pense que le format de notre
émission
prévoit au contraire vos questions
adressez à moi même non mais écoutez ça
serait intéressant pour moi de voir quel
était votre appréciation
des tendances générales aujourd'hui en
europe et dans le monde est ce que vous
partagez les peurs de cette nouvelle
guerre froide
qu'elle en parle
oui ce serait intéressant de se voir
quel était votre appréciation du
comportement
des pays occidentaux en syrie parce que
plusieurs pays sont impliqués dans ont
été impliqués dans ce conflit là donc
les questions sont innombrables
évidemment mais je pense que nous aurons
l'opportunité de s'échanger et de parler
voilà pourquoi pour nous
le dialogue les comptes à entre les gens
les contrats les contacts entre les
populations civiles les haussiers de la
société civile c'est très important
voilà pourquoi nous soutenons
les échanges décentralisées comme on dit
des échanges entre les régions de nos
deux pays qui continue malgré tout les
complicités tout les atouts de cette
conjoncture internationale pas très
propice au développement des relations
au niveau entre étatique
mais les contacts entre les sociétés
civiles entre les gens entre les régions
entre les villes entre les municipalités
c'est quelque chose qui peut améliorer
le climat même si je dois le dire
les relations franco russes aujourd'hui
reste toujours
très bon et
ce sont toujours des partenaires nous
continuons cette dialogue à tous les
niveaux et c'est très important
alors la dernière question conseil pour
les jeunes générations
si vous deviez laisser une bouteille à
la mer sur internet
oui aux jeunes qu'ils regardent
écoutent et là je pense que les jeunes à
qui appartient l'avenir de notre planète
à qui appartient
l'avenir de l'europe
doivent être responsables
doivent bien calculer tous leurs
démarches
et vraiment c'est une leçon pour nous
tous il faut calculer les résultats de
vos actions on parle de la politique
extérieure aujourd'hui donc si on part
de la politique extérieure les dernières
décennies ont démontré combien il est
important de calculer ce que vous faites
voilà la libye une exemple
très récent et la fois flagrant pour moi
on a aidé à renverser la dictature de
kadhafi
on a eu comme résultat le chaos les
pertes humaines la paupérisation de la
population la destruction du pays la
défragmentation du pays voilà donc il
faut bien calculer ce que vous faites
est dans votre vie privée et dans votre
vie professionnelle
thème sidikov merci avant de terminer
cette interview c'est un jour un peu
particulier celles à saint serge
aujourd'hui donc je voudrais souhaiter
bonne fête à tous les serge et je vous
remercie d'être venus aussi vite notre
communauté four merci merci beaucoup et
je connais en serge que nous connaissons
tous les deux je veux lui transmettre
votre message merci beaucoup
[Musique]
non